hello and welcome to this video playing
I am bill Paley more pillai i have no
idea what that means said south africa
oh I said it is right yet I wasn't sure
with South Africa or some country near
South Africa but it looks like from that
region okay got a sloppy with the Queen
B 3 and B 5 hmm that's not so frequently
seen usually played like that hmm just
doesn't play is 6 interesting
I think I'm taking keep it keep it
simple White's idea here is always to
prevent the move c5 and the outcome of
the game largely depends on that single
question is white able to prevent the
move or not if he is is better and if
not it's just absolutely nothing here
i'm slightly optimistic maybe looks like
a some chances to prevent it now left 94
now right or does it can you place your
fire for some tactics no doesn't do it
mmm okay interesting
I can just go Knight a5 and disposition
and ask him what he wants to do with
this Bishop I don't really see what is
movers you cannot note the night as I
take d6 and d7 and removes if he covers
with the look I'll take Texas six and
then be seven and d6s hanging sign looks
like a pretty awkward situation for them
I don't really see a move I seen a
little black here how is he not losing
material a maybe look a to b aj cook a b
8 9 p-7 group b 7 quincy six rook b6
just about holds and okay i know i can
take on this sex right
not yet to go yet to go hook behind
black resides it was a bad position
after OPA but buh yeah okay so that
feels like a pretty normal position here
I'm not sure about age six if you need
to do that I'm very often not against
taking on f6 any way to reduce the
number of pieces that look at the square
and it again a bit of time yeah my
development is really better this this a
form yeah hmm can I eat 6 i'm not sure i
mean i just like whitey and I will end
it what can I say it just said he
doesn't get c5 in I don't see how he
gets it in I 97-92 and now what now not
if I was coming the engine wants to play
f5 that's interesting I was also
thinking that Bishop f3 could be an
option but if I do this I think he
probably has hooks you aid it's not
clear what I'm doing now
that's not clear what I'm doing here
yeah Queenie 7 after that it gets
difficult I mean here this already looks
difficult he cannot get c5 in and if I
play like just Roxy 195 the game is
almost over strategic game because of
that Dad bishop and the very bad points
and this Knight a5 yeah now it gets very
critical he has to play book aviators
only more the absolutely only move and
then I can take take Quincy 6 and root
be sex which is continuing at least um
maybe I can take first him does this and
now yeah just go back now this is a pawn
but its its opposite colored bishops and
there's still some hope 22 how to learn
to hold not much fun but it's the best
that you could go for this is just
losing a piece maybe it was mostly
checking of this which is also not bad
but okay inside it's a full piece okay
well thanks for watching